je me tourne vers vous nicolas d'andry
de la rédaction de tv 78 on parle
économie maintenant avec l'immobilier
c'est un secteur qui est en progression
en ile-de-france les ventes de logements
anciens ont progressé de 20% au deuxième
trimestre cette année par rapport à la
même période en 2016 de bons résultats
alors qu tv nicolas comment évolue le
marché l'immobilier
alors le marché plutôt dynamique dans le
département prenons d'abord les
transactions immobilières
les ventes sont en hausse durant le
deuxième trimestre 2010 est près de
trois mille appartements anciens vendus
soit une augmentation de 23% par rapport
au second trimestre 2016 même tendance
pour les maisons anciennes vous le voyez
autour de 2500 au deuxième trimestre
2010 est une hausse de 32% par rapport à
la même période l'année dernière
mathilde très cas d'avis de notaire
associé à guyancourt nous explique les
conditions de cette situation
aujourd'hui je crois qu'un des facteurs
importants c'est quand même les taux les
taux de les taux des prêts qui sont
intéressants les gens investissent
beaucoup compté dans mon profil des taux
intéressants
et puis et puis le dynamisme
l'activité qui a autour de chez nous il
ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui s'installe
donc ça fait ça fait venir pas mal de
gens un nombre de ventes en hausse donc
dans le département qu'est ce que ça
donne sur l'évolution des prix alors
c'est l'autre signe de cette reprise sur
le marché immobilier
la tendance est aussi à la hausse si on
prend le prix moyen au mètre carré d'un
appartement ancien dans les yvelines
on passe de environ 3500 euros en 2015 à
près de trois mille sept cents en 2017
comme vous le voyez à l'image
concernant les maisons anciennes même
constat le prix moyen a augmenté de 4%
entre 2015 et le deuxième trimestre 2010
est il dépasse aujourd'hui les trois
cent soixante mille euros pour finir
nicholas vous montez sur la situation de
l'immobilier à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
que faut-il noter et bien grégory la
conjoncture est similaire à celle du
département en 2015 près de 2300
transaction immobilière avec un prix
moyen au mètre carré de 3040 euros
maisons et appartements anciens
confondus
à noter que 60 % des acquéreurs sont des
jeunes travailleurs entre 20 ans et 40
ans à ce propos je vous propose
d'écouter l'ancien président de saint
quentin en yvelines qui va parler des
facteurs d'attractivité du territoire
c'était au micro de michael et demi
d'euros il ya quelques semaines nous
avons un endroit où il ya une qualité de
vie exceptionnelle qu'avec nous sommes à
l'ouest de paris
nous sommes bien desservi aussi et alors
si on se penche plus précisément sur
certaines communes de l'agglomération
on voit que sur cette carte les prix
médian au mètre carré d'un appartement
ancien entre 2011 et le premier semestre
2016 et comme vous le voyez voisins le
bretonneux montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt ont une médiane supérieur à
3500 euros le mètre carré
on retrouve les prix les plus bas à
trappes la verrière ou encore elancourt
avec des variations de prix en fonction
de deux des quartiers comme vous le
voyez à l'image et en fonction des
couleurs chaque quartier à des prix qui
varient
même constat pour les maisons anciennes
trappe et la verrière sont les villes
les moins chères
en revanche les prix médians dépasse les
350 mille euros à magny les hameaux
voisins bretons ne guyancourt ou encore
montigny le bretonneux et justement
concernant le marché de montigny le
bretonneux je vous propose d'écouter
françois eliès qui est agent immobilier
dans cette commune sur les quelques
dernières années on a ressenti une
petite baisse de l'immobilier au niveau
national avec certaines régions qui
allait jusqu'à -15 voir -20% en termes
de baisses de prix alors que sur
montigny la baisse n'a été que de 3 à 5
points maximum c'est une baisse qui est
très très faible
pour le reste de la france du fait de
l'activité vraiment de 50 ans et de son
pôle économique alors cette situation
locale du marché immobilier sur saint
quentin en yvelines pourrait se
confirmer dans les prochaines années
notamment comme vous le savez avec
l'organisation de certaines compétitions
des jeux olympiques de 2024 sur notre
territoire
merci nicolas pour ces précisions